that was a dead broke Carpet Cleaner
living off credit cards working hard
struggling doing a good job operating
with integrity really cared but there's
no relationship between being good and
getting paid there's other people making
money in the business you're in and
you're not there's nothing wrong with
the business you're in there's something
wrong with you however I'm really big on
making money the best way to help the
pours and not be one of them
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
he's Joe polish and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one master marketing that was a dead
broke carpet cleaner living off credit
cards working hard struggling doing a
good job operating with integrity really
cared but there's no relationship
between being good and getting paid and
so until you actually learn how to sell
what it is that you're off or whatever
it is service business internet business
you know being an author speaker doctor
it doesn't matter you're in the the
marketing business and and in the
marketing business you're in really the
relationship business yeah you know how
you can either be a transaction you know
marketer or you can be a relationship
marketer and there's always as you know
there's always more money in in
relationships and I grew up incredibly
shy incredibly introverted so I'm kind
of like a introvert that learned how to
talk to people because if you don't
nothing happening is the most important
thing just like hold your breath for
three minutes and see how well you do
hold it for 5 minutes hold it for 10
minute you can't you'll die marketing is
like that for business if people's
businesses are struggling if their
missions and this is not just business
entrepreneurs this is every area of your
life I mean you know if you if you have
a partner you did some sort of marketing
there's something you did to meet the
person position yourself so to answer
the question selling is what you do when
you're on the phone or face to face with
somebody marketing is what you do to get
someone on the phone or face to face
with you so that they're properly
positioned so the key that the word
positioning is really critical so by the
time that they actually talk with you or
visit your store or go to your website
or see you speak their pre interested
pre motivated pre-qualified and
predisposed to do business with you and
I've said that a million times and I
drilled that into my head it's all about
you know pre interested pre motivated
pre-qualified predisposed and if people
if people are set up that way the whole
job of selling that selling is much
easier frankly if you have to rely on
talking someone into something then you
just aren't doing any marketing rule
number two provide value so how do you
create value with people I'm on the
plane with this guy
riki Roman and he was telling me about
his clothing company and I thought how
can I create value for this guy because
I'm wired to do this stuff on the plane
free Wi-Fi as a Christmas promotion I
send an email to Tony Hsieh who owns
Zappos and his girlfriend Jen who you
saw there and said hey I'm sitting next
to the guy who has you know founded
citron clothing and maybe you can sell
that at Zappos while we're on the plane
Tony Hsieh emails back literally in
about ten minutes he mails back and puts
him in touch with their actual
purchasing person at Zappos and Paula
Abdul actually wears his clothes they
nene has pictures with her so when he
goes back to LA which is where he lives
I'm gonna set up lunch so he can go out
with Paul and maybe get her to endorse
it that was all by sitting there talking
always think about how you can actually
promote other people and help them was I
trying to get anything about him no but
now since I'm saying this publicly I
hope he sends Jamie my girlfriend some
free clothes and then we're good rule
number three study success and so I had
a friend from high school named Pat who
actually called me up you know on a
Friday and said hey we're gonna go jet
skiing tomorrow would you like to go on
this get jet ski trip and if you don't
have any money and you're kind of in
debt it's really hard to have fun
because you're always thinking about
like am I gonna eat next I'm gonna pay
my rent that sort of thing and he said
one thing to me that caused me to go jet
ski nice oh well the guy that owns the
jet skis is a multi-million dollar real
estate investor and you know he's gonna
have one of his friends we have two jet
skis and I said yeah I'll go because I
thought to myself maybe I could talk to
this guy and I could get some advice on
what sort of business I could go into
that could maybe help me because I
wanted to go into a different industry
because I'd gotten trained and certified
in this carpet cleaning business little
entrepreneurial fantasy I had was not
working out and so I had a finally an
opportunity when we went jet skiing at
Segura Lake which is outside of you know
close to why I live in Arizona in the
Phoenix area and I sat down on the
tailgate of a pickup truck with this
real estate investor and I said to him I
said well I hear you do really well and
I have a small you know carpet cleaning
company and it's not doing that well and
I hear you you know really have a lot of
success in your business so I wanted to
ask you if you have any recommendations
of another business or another industry
that I could look at going into so I can
you know just make more money and he
said one thing to me so why are there
other
people in your industry that are making
money and I said well yeah there's
actually a couple of cleaning companies
in the you know Phoenix area that do
over a million dollars a year and to me
that's a lot of money and he said well
if there's other people making money in
the business you're in and you're not
there's nothing wrong with the business
you're and there's something wrong with
you and I was like well no no you I mean
that's you know I'm Nicole I don't do
bait-and-switch like some of these
companies that advertise a low price and
a lot of these companies are established
they've been around for a while so they
have name recognition and I would make
these excuses you say well young man
you're like many people you think the
grass is always greener on the other
side and what's going to happen if you
go into another business you're gonna
spend another six months another year
another two years learning the technical
skills of another business so you can go
out and repeat the same bad business
habits that have caused you to be a
failure in the business room right now
now that wasn't a motivational speech
that I was hoping for and I've heard
things like that before but for some
reason I mean everyone's heard when the
teachers when students ready the teacher
appears and that the teachers are
everywhere you have been teachers too
many people you're sitting next to many
teachers this genius Network event is
filled with teachers for some reason I
was receptive to it and he said what you
need to do young man is you need to
learn fundamental business skills he
said what you need to figure out how to
do is learn how to make a business work
because if other people have learned it
and you haven't you need to learn what
it is they're doing so I got really
sunburned during that trip and I
remember driving home in my pickup truck
and I thought you know I live in America
you know I'm not the smartest guy in the
world I never got a college degree in
anything I'm you know I'm an addict I'm
that's one of my biggest challenges I
was a horrible drug addict at the age of
18 and I was sitting there thinking but
I live in America and I got my limbs and
I'm in and there are people that don't
seem to be as smart as I think I am that
are doing far better than me what do
they know that I don't know and so I
made this decision that I am NOT going
to get out of this business
until I figure out how to make it work
because if I just run away from it I'm
gonna try to find something else and so
what I what I did is I started reading
and it was at that point in time that I
really took reading seriously and I said
what do I need to read
that is going to give me incredible
insight rule number four build rapport
the number one question in all consumers
Minds is who can I trust and so your job
as a business owner your job as a
marketer is to establish trust and
rapport we both have a buddy Neil
Strauss yes in Neal who's really become
a better human being over the last he's
really done a lot of work on himself
he's a good friend of mine and he wrote
a book called the game years ago and he
talked about you know building rapport
which is trust with comfort so when
you're selling something to a consumer
you've heard every marketers say know
like and trust but those are really good
words you want people to know like and
trust you and if they have no
relationship with you and you haven't
bonded with them and they don't know
anything about you why should they trust
you and so the reason people trust quote
unquote brands is because there's
familiarity you know there's a lot of
fast food companies which people should
never put any of that crap into their
throats and then you take the largest
you know brand on the planet which is
like coca-cola which is basically you
know sugar water and it's not healthy
but it's that it's the biggest brand now
our people they know what they're gonna
get though and so if you're a small
business owner you're not a big company
and you don't have billions of dollars
in decades to develop a brand so focus
on how to develop rapport based on the
benefits of what makes you so special if
you want to learn how to build
confidence from entrepreneurs like Joe
check out my 254 series it's free the
link is in the description below if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
rule number five put yourself out there
I don't like going to cocktail parties
in places where I don't know people it
makes me very uncomfortable but I
learned how to put myself out there
because you don't get checks if you
don't write okay so you got to put
yourself out there and you do that by
asking questions and tonight okay when
everyone's hanging out in the pirate
thing if you're a little shy how many of
you would be offended if someone came up
and in and to introduce themselves to
you how many of you know one how many of
you would love to meet someone new that
you haven't met
look around the room people want to meet
each other Oh
people it's hard to build rapport people
think that oh what am I going to say go
up to someone tonight and the Joe polish
question if you could have any
superpower whatsoever what would it be
and how would you use it that'll keep
you guys talking the rest of the night
even if you're drunk wearing pirate
suits
thank you okay so so this do stupid [ __ ]
you know here's me wearing hats with
Paula Abdul dr. Seuss Minnie kiss on a
donkey I like riding donkeys by the way
if you guys want to send me a donkey
that's cool rule number six learn how to
sell selling evil well my favorite
definition of selling came from my very
dear friend Dan Sullivan who is
brilliant and he said that selling is
getting someone intellectually engaged
in a future result it's good for them in
getting them to emotionally commit to
take action to achieve that result so if
you just look at that definition it's
profound
getting someone intellectually engaged
in a bigger future that's good for them
and getting them to emotionally commit
to take action to achieve that result
well if you take out the word good for
them then selling could be evil okay
meaning Martin Luther King got people
intellectually engaged in a future
result and got them to commit to take
action mother Teresa did John F Kennedy
did well so does every sales person on
the planet so did Hitler Hitler got
people intellectually and emotionally
engaged in a future result that murdered
people wasn't good in that standpoint
but saying that selling is evil is like
saying oxygen is evil oxygen is bad the
the the the human body no organism could
survive without oxygen no business can
survive no country can survive no
economy can survive and be free without
sales sales is the oxygen that makes all
of it work you eliminate sales people
you've eliminated the entire sales force
most people learn what it is they know
about cars about financial instruments
about plumbing about anything more from
salespeople than they do from school
it's the sales people that are
incentivized to actually sell a product
or service because they might actually
make some money or Commission that are
out there educating people about it
think about all of the things we know in
our life that we learned about because
we went into a store and someone told us
about it I mean you know if you go to
you know department store and someone
starts explaining how to use a DVD
player I mean it's not like you're
sitting at home watching the documentary
on you know how to a DVD player work so
I mean you learn that stuff from
salespeople so not only are salespeople
not evil salespeople are saviors
marketers are saviours they are the
carriers of messages all over the world
every significant thing that has ever
happened in mankind came because someone
was incentivized to sell it
rule number seven defines success for
yourself when someone asks me what is
success you know because I know that's a
question you ask a lot you know I mean
there's I've thought about that a lot
and what success is to me is different
than what it is to anyone else my
version of success what's most important
to me is we'll go back to a conversation
I had with an author named Poe Bronson
years ago in a book store and he's
written a bunch of books and he said
he's interviewed all kinds of people
rich poor handicapped athletes famous
you know you name it and he said you
know when you boil it down to what human
beings want is more whew unless ah you
know and I thought like you know in a
nutshell yeah it's just like I want more
whoo and I want less ah but the things
that gives me woo do I like money yeah
but not all money is created equal my
buddy Dan Sullivan who's one of my best
friend's you know these he runs it he's
coached more successful entrepreneurs
than anyone in the world someone you
definitely you should interview he's in
his 70s and he runs a program called
strategic coach and he talks about
there's five ways to get paid so and I
used to always read these books of how
much do you want to make per hour what
are you doing with your time scheduler
time are you making that and I would
always find myself spending time with
people that were interesting to me but
weren't the highest return on money I
mean there were in in activities that I
and I would find I would be like I'm not
very disciplined or what the hell's
wrong with me and why can't I focus and
what and what it ball down to when I
learned this process it's like there's
other ways to get paid other than money
so the five ways to get paid one is
reward what people give you money
the second is people utilize you they
utilize your advice I don't like
throwing pearls before swine I like
giving advice to people that will
actually use it that's why I charge a
lot of money a great ideally with handle
that
we'll make an investment so do they
utilize you three do they appreciate you
for what do they refer you in five does
it enhance you and so for me whenever I
get involved with people projects things
my number one criteria of getting
involved in a business deal getting as
one does it enhance because it simply
make me a better person like my genius
network group I get paid very well run a
multi-million dollar business and you
know you're learning and you're getting
benefits so it's like what what I found
out is does it enhance me first two
people utilize me second do they
appreciate me third do they refer me
fourth and do they pay me fifth I'm a
capitalist I like money I'm not gonna
get involved in business deals if
there's not a profitability because dumb
the thumb is important that was last
night exactly um and so so you got to be
able to have profits in order to run an
enterprise you can't employ people you
can't put stuff out to the world success
is like I could never I could have a
billion dollars but if that money came
from hurting people if it came from
extracting like you know causing
suffering selling a product that just
wish I mean I could never go to bed no
amount of money is worth the mental
anguish of guilt and shame and regret
and and now again I'm speaking for
myself like there are certain people
success to them would be not only beat
the competitor but make them hurt you
know I mean there's like different
people have a different criteria for me
though you know success is like peace of
mind rule number eight respect life
definition of greatness is when you have
true respect and admiration not ego but
true love of yourself greatness is like
dude can you truly love yourself do you
do you love the vessel that you're in
have you taken care of it you know what
one of my favorite sayings my buddy
Christian of CEO of hero X said is it's
a proverb you know he who has their
health has a thousand dreams he who does
not have their health has only one and
so if you really respect yourself you
know my ambitions my ability to build a
business my ability to talk to you right
now has to do with the fact that I'm not
late
in a hospital bed I can still function
and you you have you cannot take that
for well I guess you could take it for
granted but if you do you're gonna live
a miserable life if you don't take that
for granted if you really respect the
life you know life is the only thing
worth living for so if you're if you're
gonna have a life you know everything
you can do even if you're in pain even
your fear in depression even if you're
in struggle I mean life can be
incredibly difficult and so the thing is
is those are all signs where something
is trying to tell you pay attention you
know your life really as much as you can
create joy in yourself love yourself
that's how you're gonna be more helpful
to other people that's how you can have
a lot of friends that you're gonna you
know have an opportunity make money in
some cases you won't make money I mean
some people are not here to make money
they're here to have great families and
they're here to you know people that
work in hospice centers and I mean
there's so many things that humans do
that they're amazing but at the end of
the day you know if you want to be a
million dollar racehorse you don't run
it into the ground you don't feed it
crappy food you don't never let it rest
you literally take care of it if it's
gonna win million-dollar races you feed
it well you know it well you don't let
it hang out with toxic people you don't
have it hang out in toxic environments
you take care of that million-dollar
racehorse because if you do it will
perform very well so that's the way you
know greatness is literally taking care
of yourself and in the process and
you're able to take care of others
because you can't fix the world with
broken hands rule number nine get money
however I'm really big on making money
the best way to help the poor's and not
be one of them and if you want to do
some whenever you put the word social in
front of anything it's sort of demeans
it the most social people in the world
they're entrepreneurs and capitalists
make loads of money give people jobs
create value in the world that's the way
to live and rule number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
five
hands off hands off way
what are you going to say to the
cameraman
actually that was awesome that was
awesome and I now we got a special bonus
clip from Joe on the importance of
reading that I really think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action in your life for business here we
go question number one what does your
definition of success look like number
two where do you need to put yourself
out there more and number three which
three people will you commit to studying
success from reading is probably the
most effective form of learning in
existence and a lot of people want stuff
give me the free advice but they're not
willing to then pursue it read it learn
it digest it that sort of stuff and in
my area of a focus which is direct
response marketing I'm a huge fan of
obviously the classic books if you want
to learn marketing read Ogilvy on
advertising by David Ogilvy one of the
greatest marketing books of all time
read scientific advertising and my life
in advertising by Claude Hopkins
absolute must reads read the Robert call
your letter book by Robert Collier
phenomenal book thanks for watching this
video if you want more information about
me go to Joe polish dot-com like nail
polish
if you want to learn how to win the game
of life go check out the video there
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I think the single biggest reason
why people have bad days is because they
start them off by looking around at
everybody else and seeing what they're
doing